[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
das rezept für einen leckeren
bienenstich der bienenstich besteht aus
einem süßen hefeteig mit einer leckeren
honig mandeln kruste und einer füllung
aus vanille und sahne
wir starten zuallererst mit dem süßen
hefeteig und hierfür benötigen wir mehr
lauwarme milch frische hefe ihr könnt
auch trockene verwenden außerdem etwas
salz zucker und flüssige butter
[Musik]
die ganz genauen mengenangaben stehen
wie immer unten in der infobox und wir
starten indem wir das mehl in eine
ausreichend große schüssel geben
in der mitte bilden wir dann eine kleine
mulde geben die lauwarme milch hinzu und
bröseln die hefe damit rein
[Musik]
anschließend geben wir etwas von dem
zucker mit hinzu damit die hefe besser
aufgehen kann verrühren das kurz
miteinander und lassen das zehn minuten
abgedeckt stehen
[Musik]
nach der ruhezeit ist die hefe schaumig
geworden und wir geben die restlichen
zutaten mit hinzu
[Musik]
mit den händen kneten wir dann alle
zutaten zu einem hefeteig
[Musik]
falls euer etwas größer sein sollte dann
benötigt ihr etwas mehr mail der teig
darf nicht mehr kleben sondern sollte
gerade so geschmeidig sein
[Musik]
auf der arbeitsfläche knete ich den teig
dann noch einmal und rolle ihn
anschließend zu einer kugel
[Musik]
den hefeteig geben wir dann direkt in
unsere mit backpapier ausgelegte
springform
die springform hat übrigens einen
durchmesser von 26 cm und kleiner würde
ich den bienenstich auch nicht machen
und jetzt verteilen wir den teig
gleichmäßig bis hin zum rand nun lassen
wir den teig in der springform zugedeckt
gehen mindestens eine halbe stunde noch
besser sind aber 45 minuten für die
leckere füllungen benötigen wir
milchzucker speisestärke vanille extrakt
oder das mag einer vanilleschote ein
eigelb außerdem kalte schlagsahne und
seine stand mittel aus dem ersten fünf
zutaten bereite ich jetzt ein vanille
pudding zu
falls ihr lieber den vanillepudding aus
der tüte nehmen möchte dann tut dies
gerne ich mache den immer am liebsten
selber bevor wir damit starten gebe ich
einen kleinen teil der milch zusammen
mit den restlichen zutaten in eine
schüssel und früher das klümpchen frei
[Musik]
dann geht es rüber zum herd und ich gebe
die restliche milch in meinen kochtopf
und lasse das einmal aufkochen
[Musik]
damit die milch am topfboden nicht
anbrennt könnt ihr dabei ständig
umrühren und sobald das ganze aufkocht
gebt ihr eure restliche mischung mit
hinzu nun lassen wir das ganze noch mal
auf kochen bis es ein dicht und wir
einen leckeren vanillepudding erhalten
den vanillepudding gebe ich dann ganz
gerne durch ein sieb ihr müsst es nicht
tun aber so stellt er sicher dass keine
klümpchen entstehen
anschließend gebe ich direkt darüber
frischhaltefolie damit sich keine haut
bildet und lasse den pudding vollständig
abkühlen
mit der sahne geht es dann erst weiter
sobald der pudding abgekühlt ist
in der zwischenzeit stellen wir den
leckeren mandl belag her
hierfür benötigen wir gehobelte mandeln
butter zucker etwas sahne honig und
vanille extrakt
in einem topf oder eine pfanne lassen
wir die butter zusammen mit der sahne
schmelzen
[Musik]
anschließend geben wir den honig und den
zucker mit hinzu schalten den herd aus
und verrühren das gut miteinander
[Musik]
sobald sich die masse dann gut verbunden
hat geben wir nur noch die gehobelte
mandeln mit hin zu grünen das gut um und
dann ist der belag auch schon fertig
[Musik]
inzwischen ist der hefeteig auch schon
aufgegangen und wir geben unseren mandl
belag direkt gleichmäßig auf den
hefeteig
[Musik]
hierbei müsst ihr sehr vorsichtig und
behutsam sein denn ihr dürft den
hefeteig nicht eindrücken sondern den
belag nur ganz leicht darüber geben und
verteilen
[Musik]
nun wird das ganze im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 180 grad ober und
unterhitze fit 20 minuten gebacken
während der hefeteig im ofen backen
machen wir mit der creme weiter dafür
gebe ich die kalte schlagsahne zusammen
mit dem sonnenstand mittel in die
küchenmaschine anschlag das ganze steif
[Musik]
das geben wir dann ganz kurz an die
seite und machen mit dem vorbereiteten
und abgekühlten vanillepudding weiter
damit der pudding jetzt aufgelockert
wird und wie die sahne besser unter
heben können ruhig das ganze nochmal mit
dem flach hörer ihr könnt
selbstverständlich auch euren
schneebesen verwenden
nach ein paar sekunden ist der pudding
dann auch etwas geschmeidiger und wir
haben vorsichtig die sonne unter am
allerbesten funktioniert das in dem ihr
die sahne mit einem teig scheibe in zwei
bis drei schritten unter hebt
die fertige cremen geben wir dann bis
zur weiterverarbeitung in den
kühlschrank
nachdem der hefeteig gebacken und
vollständig ausgekühlt ist befreien wir
ihn von der springform und teilen ihn
anschließend in der mitte einmal durch
[Musik]
den oberen teil mit der mandel kruste
nehme ich mir dann mit einem torten
retter weg und den unteren teil gebe ich
mir auf eine schöne tortenplatte
[Musik]
das backpapier können wir dann ganz
einfach entfernen und legen einen
tortenring drumherum
[Musik]
nun geben wir die vollständige creme
darüber und streichen das ganze glatt
[Musik]
für den anstieg der torte ist es sehr
wichtig dass wir den deckel jetzt schon
zurechtschneiden und hier könnt ihr
selber entscheiden wie viele stücke ihr
später haben möchtet
mein torten deckel habe ich durch acht
geteilt ich habe es mal wieder zu gut
gemeint und die stücke waren wirklich
sehr groß ich rate euch teilt ihnen in
mindestens zwölf stücke ein
[Musik]
damit die creme auch schön fest wird
kommt die torte jetzt für weitere zwei
stunden in den kühlschrank
[Musik]
nach der schulzeit ist unser leckerer
bienenstich auch schon fertig und ihr
könnt ihn euch schmecken lassen
[Musik]
hier seht ihr im anschnitt auch das
verhältnis zwischen creme und hefeteig
und ich finde ihn wirklich perfekt
falls ihr jetzt auch lust habt diesen
köstlichen bienenstich nach zu backen
dann schaut auf jeden fall unten in die
infobox da habe ich nochmal alle genauen
mengenangaben für euch aufgeschrieben
[Musik]
falls ihr kein rezept mehr verpassen
möchte dann hinterlasst mir auf jeden
fall ein kostenloses abo und dann freue
ich mich aufs nächste mal tschüss